that's a class for oppression that's  okay she seems peaceful my name is Aaron  Gilbert doctor of particle physics  that's step one everywhere  by the way in every crack very hard to  wash off we have dedicated our whole  lives to studying the paranormal now  their sightings all over the city there  are people out there that need our help  peltzman you're a brilliant engineer  Aaron no one's better at quantum physics  than you we can provide a real service  I'm joining the club you guys are really  smart about this science stuff but I  know New York and I can borrow a car  from my uncle you didn't disclose if the  vehicle was gonna be a hearse  let's go let's go oh did you want to  race I liked you I do except someone is  creating a device that amplifies  paranormal activity we might be the only  ones who can stop it come on  the Hat is too much right is it the  wiggers that  here's a bigger picture at hand here  these ghosts can possess the human form  Oh  yes dr. Jain